inside FBI headquarters the Acting
Director is pushing agents to focus on
their work Andrew McCabe has taken over
the Russian investigation as commis
replacement president Trump met with
McCabe for a second time yesterday to
discuss the bureau there are reports
that morale has taken a hit after commis
firing Jeff pjs is outside FBI
headquarters in Washington Jeff good
morning good morning the White House
isn't wasting any time it is moving
quickly to find an interim FBI director
until the president chooses commis
permanent replacement the firings
stunned the FBI which is right in the
midst of this Russia investigation one
of the most important in its history
it's one of at least five people who
have already been interviewed at the
Justice Department for the job of
interim director of the FBI according to
sources the way Comey found out about
his dismissal surprised some inside the
bureau he was visiting the Los Angeles
field office talking with agents when
news reports flashed on TV screens that
he had been fired many field agents also
received the news through the media he
was no longer had the confidence of the
President or the rest of the FBI some
Bureau agents and employees tell CBS
News they took issue with White House
spokesperson Sarah Huckabee Sanders
claimed that Comey lost the confidence
of rank-and-file FBI employees Timothy
Murphy is a former Deputy Director of
the FBI director Comey was well liked by
the employees you may have had a number
of employees in the organization that
may have disagreed with his approach on
his handling of the email investigation
but overall director Comey built up a
lot of goodwill in the FBI about the way
he treated people the respect he had for
the employees of the organization law
enforcement sources tell CBS News that
the FBI Russia investigation had been
picking up speed in recent weeks FBI
agents in the US and overseas have been
intensely focusing on following the
money trying to identify who might have
paid hackers involved in Russia's
campaign to interfere in the 2016
election Murphy says a change at the top
should not affect any ongoing
investigations the bureau will carry on
its mission like they have for the last
hundred years I have great confidence in
leadership in the bureau and they're
going to be working together to keep the
FBI intact but whoever president Trump
chooses to permanently leave the FBI can
influence any investigation by adding or
pulling resources and that's why the
firing this week set off alarms here in
Washington not only on Capitol Hill but
in the halls of the FBI as well Charlie
thanks Jeff